let's get stuck in early doors why is
football so full of cliches broadly
speaking there are two types of football
cliche firstly there are the hyper
truths phrases which are so obvious that
they're not even worth repeating that
really was a game of two halves or if
you don't shoot you can't score these
hyper truths have persisted because
they're comforting reliable filler the
footballing equivalent of say talking
about the weather with your in-laws then
there is the received wisdom football
phrases that have become accepted as
truth despite having almost no basis in
logic when a fan repeats such myths
some people say you can score too early
all that to nil is always a dangerous
score it taps into their most primal
fear that their team will suddenly and
spectacularly let them down paranoia and
pessimism are after all central to the
enjoyment of football for all that the
English language of football has evolved
into something rather or named over the
last hundred and fifty years other
countries have embraced their more
poetic side what we might describe as
postage-stamp
that is the extreme top corner of the
goal the Brazilians might call on Jade
or Mia kirusha literally where the owl
sleeps while English has countless ways
to describe the fundamental route to
scoring a goal none are quite as
evocative as the French affair tumblr
lefel a make the nets quiver suddenly
getting in a back of the onion bag
doesn't quite sound so impressive
football commentary is awash with
bizarre words and phrases
borrowed from other walks of life often
from decades ago when else in their
day-to-day life would the average
football fan use the words aplomb that
is a goal scored tidally but with a
flourish or some wash buckling once used
for eighteenth century pirate's but now
for a defender who has a habit of
suddenly bursting upfield to join the
attack the development of the football
lexicon has largely been a one-way
street but it has given the occasional
word or phrase back to the wider english
language back to square one again
some claim originates from the BBC's
radio coverage in the 1920s when a
commentator would refer to a grid system
printed in the Radio Times to indicate
where the ball was on the pitch at that
moment
despite the negative connotation cliches
do have a useful function they exist to
fill gaps to lubricate debate interact
as a conversational leveler between a
novice and an expert so with the
saturation of football coverage spare a
thought for the much-maligned cliche
because at the end of the day where
would we be without them
you